[music playing]
This is one of the
deadliest places on earth.
Every known virus is here.
It's going to seem
very claustrophobic.
People panic.
They scream.
You need to be straight
with me, can you do this?
[music playing]
Jaax, something I need
you to take a look at.
What are we testing for?
Ebola Zaire.
Ebola has never been
detected on US soil.
There's a first
time for everything.
I have a husband, two kids.
We have a duty to protect them.
You always fight so hard.
[music playing]
Hole.
Hole, hole.
Oh my god.
[music playing]
You're scaring the
hell out of me, Nanc.
I need to get back in there.
And there's a chance
that it's Ebola.
They may already be in
the midst of an outbreak.
What did you do?
Do you have any idea what
kind of panic this would cause?
There's no cure, no vaccine.
Mortality rate is 90%.
It's here.
You brought it back here?
It spreads through
bodily fluids.
When we show each
other affection
It's learning.
It's evolved.
It will wipe us out if
we don't get ahead of it.
Woah.
You're going to
get us all killed.
I'm trying to
keep my family safe.
I won't cover this up for you.
[music playing]
[siren]